KEEPING A CLOSE EYE ON THE
SITUATION.
>> THAT THEY ARE.
THE PRESIDENT FOR HIS PART HAS
BEEN QUIET ON THE SUBJECT TODAY.
NOT SO MUCH AS A SINGLE TWEET
ABOUT THE SITUATION IN IRAQ.
BUT HIS REACTION HAS SPOKEN WITH
CLARITY.
>> THEY GOT IN AND THERE WAS NO
PROBLEM WHATEVER.
>> THERE WERE SURPRISING
PARALLELS BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT'S NEW YEAR'S EVE GALA
AND THE U.S. MARINES IN THE
EMBASSY IN BAGHDAD.
A PROJECTION OF CALM AMID UNREST
HALF A WORLD AWAY.
>> IT WAS HANDLED WELL.
THE MARINES CAME IN.
THEY WERE THERE INSTANTANEOUSLY.
THIS WON'T BE A BENGHAZI.
>> THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE FACILITIES IN BAGHDAD AND
BENGHAZI, THE FORMER IS A
750-MILLION DOLLARS FORTIFIED
BUILDING.
THE PRESIDENT'S POINT ABOUT A
QUICK RESPONSE UNDERSCORES THE
THREAT TO U.S. PERSONNEL AND
PROPERTY AND THE STRAINS OF
HISTORY THAT HAS SEEN CHAOS AND
CARNAGE.
THE PRESIDENT WHO ACCUSED TEHRAN
OF BEING RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
EMBASSY ASSAULT ORDERED 750
SOLDIERS DEPLOYED TO THE MIDDLE
EAST AND 3,000 MORE PREPARE FOR
POSSIBLE DEPLOYMENT INCLUDING
THE IMMEDIATE DEPLOYMENT OF THE
82nd AIRBORNE, AN ACTION TAKEN
IN RESPONSE TO INCREASED THREAT
LEVELINGS AGAINST U.S.
PERSONNEL.
>> DO NOT CONFUSE PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S PATIENT WITH WEAKNESS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE REGIME HAS
DONE THAT.
>> CRITICISM OF THE PRESIDENT'S
DECISIONS HAS BEEN MUTED SOME
DEMOCRATS BLAME THE UNREST IN
IRAQ ON HIS SHOULDERS.
CONNECTICUT DEMOCRAT TWEETED
IT'S HARD TO OVERSTATE HOW BADLY
TRUMP HAS BUCK BUNGLED THINGS IN
THE MIDDLE EAST -- THANKS TO
TRUMP'S MISHANDLING OF IRAN
POLICY.